[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits I'm Brett and
I'm Linc it's time for another candid
conversation with someone interesting
from the internet this week that person
is YouTube vlogger Tyler Oakley we
talked with him about his struggle with
an eating disorder that began in middle
school and also him being outed as gay
in a very dramatic way during high
school so yeah we we get in all these
things stay tuned for that conversation
but first I do want to talk to you about
something linked that my life has been
seriously affected by yet another
documentary and I feel like this
directly affects you you now we've
discussed this on good mythical morning
before we're avid Netflix Watchers
there's a whole documentary section
which is very tempting but you just have
to know when you're clicking on a
documentary that it could it could ruin
something for you it could it could
enlighten you and simultaneously ruin
something for you and so we talked about
the hot coffee thing and that's where
you're going with this well yeah but
this one and this one in particular has
not made his way to Netflix yet CNN oh
really doing these things that I get the
scald at the CNN film where they dock
you I don't know how long they've done
this but they document something in a
very impactful way that's obviously made
to sort of like change your opinion
about something
and so CNN films recently released a
blackfish which is a film about orcas or
killer whales in captivity specifically
at SeaWorld but they're okay at SeaWorld
mostly I mean they're also they were
also at a place called sea land but then
mostly at SeaWorld it's really about
SeaWorld today first of all did they
dispel the myth that killer whales are
mammals are they fish are they blackfish
well actually the is that what the
premise of the documentary is that
they're not actual whales they're people
in suits it's a nice it's a mind-blowing
it is absolutely mind-blowing its
puppetry I hate how these documentaries
can ruin it for you I mean I went to
SeaWorld I was like this is amazing
but it's just a it's no way is that a
human in that huge suit yeah it's not
animatronic because of the water the
whole thing would short out it's a
person inside there
one guy inside that thing and he's got
like pedals oh man he believed he is
getting a workout that killer go well
okay obviously that's not true but what
is true is that maybe one day it will be
a dude inside of a killer whale suit
because after this documentary if people
see if you watch this documentary you
will not go back to Sea World and this
isn't one of those things where this is
a you know oh well this is just one side
of the story if you guys see the other
side of the story you'll be all about
SeaWorld and this in really the orcas
love it there at SeaWorld no no this is
this is the thing where these mammals
they are yes they are mammals that you
are correct about that I mean incredibly
intelligent mammals with brains larger
than ours with emotional centers in
their brains that are very powerful some
may argue even more powerful than ours
who are experiencing life in a bathtub
essentially for years and becoming
incredibly frustrated and suffering some
physical problems like dorsal fin
collapse and that kind of thing but I
can see how it would be sad I mean when
I went to SeaWorld I felt a tinge of
sadness you did it just a tinge though
that it kind of felt like exploitation
and then what Shamu splashed you and
your kid you're like what no and I
understand that because you know you
know first okay I want deep does it go
is it just all there in there in small
confined spaces when they belong in the
ocean I mean I get that but the well
it's kind of two there's two parts to it
there is these killer whales are killers
and they have killed multiple trainers
especially this one Tilikum I can't
remember I can never remember how to
pronounce his name but he's the he's the
male basically who has sired most all
killer whales that have been born in
captivity he was captured in the 70s and
he was kept around for a long
timing took place called Ceylon and then
he was at SeaWorld and he's killed like
three trainers and and like a dude that
was just happen to get into the tank one
night it happened to get into the tank
yeah some dude and I mean and this
graphic stuff I mean like this you know
this you can see the documentary but
like the they come in one morning and
Tilikum has a naked man that he's
parading around on his back he stripped
the guy's clothes stripped his clothes
off and are the guy was skinny-dipping
and what he thought was a pond no and
the the freaking killer whale had bitten
his genitals off I mean that's just a
fact people the killer whale did that
and and we're talking about a killer
whale that is incredibly smart yeah that
they have complex language they talk all
about how they talk they have a language
that is specific to the pod that they
grew up in the family that they grew up
in and they stay with their mom for
their entire life through adulthood
their entire life and then they're
putting these different killer whales
from different pods in this little
bathtub essentially and getting them to
jump around for fish and then they're
like oh but they got this great
relationship with the trainers yeah
until they kill the trainers so now
actually because of some law that was
passed the trainer's can't be in the
water with it right when I went there
were no trainers in the water right so
what I mean what's the fun in that
anyway so anyway it's just one of those
things I don't you know I'm not the the
documentary does a much better job of
summarizing this whole thing but it was
just one of those things that got ruined
for me because I went to because this is
about you yeah this is all about me and
my personal entertainment in the in
potential weekend outings with my
children to be a good dad you know and
so the flip side of the story is oh well
because of SeaWorld we know all about
killer whales and we're appreciative of
you know marine life and we want to have
them protected and all that but you know
the long story short is that if you want
to go to SeaWorld don't watch the CNN
documentary that's the law Yeah right
I'm not gonna go to SeaWorld and you
can't go anymore either I'm sorry okay
well if anyone wants an annual pass to
SeaWorld I'm gonna be making an eBay
listing very soon no I don't have an
annual pass but I don't need to see
documentary you know
need to go back let's shift gears to
tyler oakley i think it's you know it's
it's gonna go to some serious places
kind of like this documentary
conversation no more talk about SeaWorld
though but yeah I mean Tyler has I would
say skyrocketed to vlogger Fame on
YouTube by being himself and such a
great personality he talks about that
he's approaching two and a half million
subscribers on his YouTube channel
youtube.com slash Tyler Oakley and this
is a recent rise fame relatively recent
that happened in 2012 and of course in
2013 and we talked to him all about that
from the very beginning to the present
and maybe even a little bit of the
future here it is our conversation with
Tyler Oakley and I'm going to airplane
load it up sound good I put it on here
I've been calling it Airport mode go
through security
unless it's an airport mode well that's
the good thing about having a friend
like it's always looking for the
mistakes that I'm making and so that he
can brutally point them out now are you
the kind of person that puts your phone
do you really cut the phone off when
they say to cut it off or do you do this
thing when you hit the top and it goes
black and they can't tell yeah no I
never put on airplane mode oh well I do
when I need to like when I'm about to
loose battery but do you power the phone
off and they're like please power off
all so but once everyone's life it once
a flight attendant was like there is one
phone that our airplane has detected
that is still on and everyone on the
flight was like scramble phone like as
if they could track the person down
right that was and I was like all of you
are fools that's a great technique that
it worked
I said not for me I had the woman next
to me one time just a stranger I was
finishing up a text and like and she was
like are you gonna cut that
off and I was like yeah she said what
you haven't yet I'm like tweeting to the
very last second
truly like until like my phone loses
reception I'm still like working on my
phone and are you tweeting as if it
could be your last always I always think
I will I'm morbid like that cuz I gotta
be a lot and I think like okay well if
this is the one what's my last tweet
because I've seen some last celebrity
tweets like after they're gone I go to
their Twitter I'm like you know if I
were to list one hobby that's a last
tweet hmm some people like a famous last
words
I like famous lost tweets right well so
you sincerely think about that you're
not joking I'm not literally not joking
and do you remember the last one that
you decided to tweet on the last flight
I have I love you all is it I love you
mom or no probably not
there's probably something about our
cute flight attendant so I don't really
take my own advice I don't I don't put
out a good last tweet you're flirting
yeah all the way to heaven
okay you're just saying that you like
the idea of being prepared to have a
life last week you think about it but
you actually don't practice don't maybe
I think usually my last tweets when I'm
leaving somewhere it's like it's been
real
insert place here but like I guess it's
not very epic for like a last tweet of
all s tweets but you you tweet a lot me
how many times you do it in a day oh
goodness me I don't know too many hey
whoever has notifications for my tweets
got to be going through it their their
phone life has got to be gone done
especially because I delete tweets like
three times in a row because I see typos
each time so like I fix it and then I
see it tweet or another type of a night
delete it oh really so like if if they
get that my tweets to their phone that's
a lot to deal with you delete tweets
you're a deleter
I'm a little eater do you schedule
tweets I used to but not anymore
you're just a real-time in it yeah but I
do have on my computer I have you know
how you can go to like all your sticky
notes yeah then I have like 30 well
however my sticky notes fit it's all
sticky notes and it's all like tweet
ideas and then the bottom row
like all it completed tweets that I know
I want to tweet it sometime so if I'm
like uninspired for the day I can just
take one throw it up copy and paste it
so you do some observational tweets
isn't just like I'm on a plane now yeah
yeah it's very much just like you know
it is a horror say like if I have
something like about Space Jam well
someday it'll trend on Twitter and when
it's trending I have a tweet applicable
for it oh you have tweets loaded and
ready to give so if anything happens
there's a base jam well not necessarily
Space Jam but yes I have one for Space
Jam you know what I would like to
spoiler alert what is it I would never
tell you you're gonna use it when it's
trending now I'm very interested in
coming back to this because massara lee
specifically Space Jam but the way that
you think about social media because
that's something that we discussed
before when we talked about you know
getting people to like our videos and
that kind of thing we're like well how
do what does Tyler do here because it's
not know seriously oh yeah we've had
multiple conversations that we've like
gone to your Instagram and your YouTube
and we're like look he's got look he's
people are like how he's asking them to
like this and he's a master of this this
interaction thing I think it's all down
to admitting to the people yes it is
shameless and yes it's gonna continue
but it's all for the better cause of
more or more this coming as long as
y'all push like oh no yeah there's no
shame in it I'm just trying to emulate
it but I want I want to come back to
that sure we want to go back to the
beginning I'm gonna go back to you know
wherever you were conceived wherever
that happened what would've been your
first tweet in Jackson Michigan you want
to know what my first tweet was I do
know my actual first tweet okay um it
was rubbing mic on my Twitter I looked
it up you there's a website where you
can look and I'm like what was I
thinking back in 2008 and you're how do
you feel about that now well I looked
and it has like six thousand retweets
because I mentioned it once in a video
and so I think everyone went to go find
it and retweet it so it must be
successful in some capacity well it
rhymes yeah well any time you could
rhyme a tweet yeah that's what I'm here
for that one was on a sticky note like
years before Twitter wasn't an actual
sticky like whenever this thing that
requires 40 characters or less
I know what I'm gonna push 140 but I do
think that that one would have fit under
40 48 for said 40 I wasn't gonna call
you I also said airport mode that's
always so short my standards are higher
I was like man he's only you know like
forwards so what would have been your
first tweet as an infant in foot it's
just my stupid way of saying talk about
where you were born or it would probably
be about something about my first I
think one of my first memories is
watching Aladdin and I don't know if ha
I don't know how old I was for that so
it would probably be about 11 I just
distinctly remember being in like my
living room back in the back of the day
okay see Jackson Jackson Michigan
Michigan where is that on the hand we
are going right here right in the middle
right now a little palm okay if you're
familiar with the way you can hold up
your hand and see Michigan that's what's
happening here only people in the
Midwest know that so there's no lake
there right in the middle now I can't
offer you yeah bummer so what was life
like growing up there as a as a
youngster life was watching some Aladdin
what a fine um so I kind of grew up in
like a I guess you would say like more
urban area and I lived in like a rural
area so like I went to school like and
very very what you would imagine
Michigan public schools are I'm like the
stereotype of like Detroit you know what
I mean kind of like heart you know and
it's clearly I thrived so hardened
people yeah going to school at a young
age like like kinda like prison it would
feel like that I had a suburb of Detroit
no no no no but it's why would it matter
what you okay got you that's how Jackson
was um I don't know what it's like now I
haven't been like forever but um yeah I
grew up there but I lived kind of like
in the country ish okay I'm like in a
little neighborhood
uh so we're not talking raising animals
on a farm no um like in the woods kind
of like making goat cheese no I wish
help coach it's really easy you just put
goat milk in like a bag and keep
squeezing other milk really eventually
it becomes cheese yeah I just learned
about it this weekend we'll talk about
that later
what what's the family situation so the
family situation at this point my
parents got divorced when I was super
young maybe like two or three okay so
that's all I ever knew and so it was
live with your mom living with my mom my
sister who I was closest with lived with
my dad and I didn't really get along
with my dad my sister didn't really get
along with my mom but me and my sister
got along so we would kind of relay
information about what was going on with
each family like really how much doing
Jackson mmm but they also in Jackson
everybody was in Jackson this was until
I was like 12 okay how much older with
your sister that was with you yes two
years older so but I had tons of steps
and halves and stuff because my parents
both got remarried within the next like
two years okay
so growing up I like in my home I had
about I think six kids probably really
if I were to count them yeah which you
were the oldest no I was the youngest
because the new steps were old gotcha so
it was very like mixed family like a
whole bunch of siblings from all
different parents like previous
marriages upon previous marriages so I
was the youngest and me and my siblings
were all very close so we I think I
always thought like we were kind of the
outcasts of the neighborhood like that's
how I always perceived it I know like
growing up we were really poor and I
always felt like we talked in here what
do you give me a poor like poor like
like you didn't eat food no we had food
but like my parents went out like their
business failed and I think there was
like debt issues and like and what kind
of business like was it and then what
did they go on to do that well let me
tell you okay so for the sake of taking
out all the drama but now we want the
drama I don't know if my parents want me
they'll listen my mom listen stuff you
can change their name sure well I know
one one business that my parents ran
that is actually really interesting I've
always want to make a video about it but
I didn't know how I would I think if I
do I need my mom to explain it because
it's just so ludicrous my stepdad was
kind of like a carpenter in some
capacity I don't know like how official
it was but he made hutches and things
and they had a store called Papa Woody's
woodshop and I don't know why it was
called that but my mom did crafts within
the store and so she made like
scrunchies and seasonal scrunchies and
like like a Halloween scrunchie and it
sounds like an assortment just one thing
it was just scrunchies and plot twists
Papa Woody's wood shop one day was
burned to the ground well that happens
when it's all wood squatches are highly
fancy scrunchies in wood there's just a
fire way now like this an accident or
what and that is the mystery so some
speculate that it could have been some
type of ex-lover situation some like
ex-husband Eric's wife that had done the
deed your dad I don't know who's who but
because there are a lot of X's in this
like equation everyone has been married
and remarried multiple times um but some
scream foul play and so at the time I'm
like seven and I'm like thinking there
is some type of conspiracy people are
trying to burn down my house like so it
was like rough times for jung-tae play
but you were how old when you couldn't
that when you were going through this I
think I was like probably eight okay
something I'm so I knew that was going
on and I knew at the time my dad was
trying to get custody of me and so there
was a lot of like tension there so like
my worst nightmare was parent-teacher
conferences like going to parent-teacher
conferences knowing that my mom and dad
would be in the same building hmm like I
would have panic attacks I would like
burst into tears like it was just too
much for they were not civil oh no they
hated each other at one point well yes
they hated each other at one point at
one point they hated each other so much
that went down
that is beside the point not my she
around you put a scrunchie DEP is there
multiple uses for them yeah so that is I
guess yeah what of what I've always
known is that my parents I've never
known my parents to enjoy each other's
company did you did your dad get custody
or was that no it sounds like you didn't
want to live with your dad no and but he
fought and so I would always have to go
to court
this is like before I was number ten
like I would have to go to court and
like talk to the judge about like who I
wanted to live with and things like that
that's sad it's very stressful in but
that was all I knew so like I thought
like this was what people had to deal
with and what I mean
was it just a spite kind of thing it was
just like I'm gonna get Tyler from you
or was it just like I don't like the guy
that you're with a little bit of that I
think a little bit of I think I can
raise them better a little bit of I
don't know parenting styles or I well I
would assume if you hate your partner
you don't want your child to be with
your partner so I don't know if that was
it you know what do you think was the
key difference between the house that
your mom was creating in the house that
your dad had well growing up my dad and
stepmom were wealthier and like my
siblings that lived in that house went
to like a private school stuff like that
and then at my mom and stepdads house it
was like poorer but like a lot more
communal like you know just felt like
family ish whereas over there didn't I
didn't like like we didn't I don't know
if we hugged but like it wasn't like
loving like they loved like everyone
loved each other but they nobody showed
it you know what I mean right
I don't know just different different
but at the house that you're living in
its kind of the Brady Bunch here we've
got six kids yeah and you're getting
along with with your your step brothers
and sisters yeah I was a little though
like they all hated me and they tell me
to this day they're like I don't know
how you turned into who you are now
because like growing up you were the
worst
he's like everyone was like it was
common know I was I just with everything
like we had chores I would like you
didn't life stuff on fire did you no no
I did not burn down Papa ways without it
but like I would instead of mopping like
for example I would just toss
a bucket of water everywhere and just
walk out in sight or like you know I'm
just like a little were you getting in
trouble at school also or was it just
like a messing with your brothers and
sisters it was maybe it was some type of
now that I'm like self diagnosing mm-hmm
maybe I was just rebelling I needed
control of my life in some capacity and
how long did this behavior last until I
was like 18 Lord no my I was always
grounded all throughout middle school
all throughout high school like I was a
bad kid so what was your quality of life
like getting into grade school middle
school years tell us about that sure so
started an elementary school in Jackson
and then when I was in sixth grade I
moved to oka Miss which is about an hour
away so my whole mom and stepdad family
moved to Oak amiss and up into that
point I was pretty overweight I was like
very into the Old Navy tech vests like
just rocking that style and like camo
pants like I had a bull cut it was just
not a good look overall so I was not
popular okay I what were you doing for
fun for fun
what were you into I was very into so I
was on the soccer team but I hated it um
what else did I do
I was very into collecting things so I
would collect depending on what I was
obsessed with so first it was like Power
Rangers and then it was pogs and then it
was Pokemon Pokemon was like a big part
of my life I would like go to
competitions like at the local video
game store and like what was I steak -
or just more Pokemon you know I don't
know I never won I could have won I
never realized the benefit but you were
obsessive about these type of things
yeah
for fourth grade I remember my birthday
I asked everyone that I invited to my
birthday for a yo-yo and I ended up with
like 20 yo-yos and my parents were
furious they're like we have to take all
these back but one all you need is one
so we went to the kiosk in the mall
where they sold yo-yos and I returned
all of them but one and I never even
know how to yo-yo like I just it was
like a status symbol like everyone else
was CEO Ewing yeah okay as someone
as someone who grew up knowing this guy
you know and knowing was pointing to me
what he was like as a child and what
he's like now he's very much a collector
too you know he would it was like if he
had won of something he had to then get
all the rest of those things is that
like is that what you were doing I
probably had nine yo-yo series sure as a
kid that was me missing with like beanie
babies and so I you know with link that
didn't have beanie babies I was obsessed
and I had a valuation book - is that
because you were gay yes it was that was
actually why I turned gay that's beanie
babies SCU mm-hmm so you sort of ended
up you're still very anal is the word
not that yo-yos there like that and very
much about having things orderly and
that kind of thing so is that is that
still part of your personality did that
kind of carry through
I mean maybe yeah like to this day when
it comes to YouTube I'm very all-in I'm
very like I want like when it comes to
my career I guess yeah like I'm I'm very
focused on what like I want to obtain
then I want it all you know what I mean
right you want to collect I'll collect
all of YouTube all of YouTube all the
viewers
okay so you're collecting beanie babies
and expanding these collections and
moving from one thing to the next being
obsessive the the weight thing the whole
not having friends what's the dynamic
there um when I went so I was moving off
to a new school a sixth grade moved to a
new city so I didn't know anybody um and
I was overweight and just trying to
figure out who I was at the time I was
also kind of figuring out that I was gay
and so it was just like a lot was
working against me it felt like and at
the time also I knew like my dad and
stepmom were against you know the whole
gay thing my mom and stepdad had have
always been like very openly like
supportive of anything you know that
would could ever be of any of their kids
but um just trying to figure that out
was stressful
and so going into sixth grade was kind
of like the worst because like I just
didn't know anyone and it was just like
intimidating because I also didn't I
felt like I didn't know myself so like
how do I like make friends if I don't
even know how to present myself because
I was figuring it like okay well I'm
asking to feminine or I'm acting to this
sort I am too fat or like you know
whatever hmm
so just figuring all that out was a
stressor how did you figure it out I
mean as a sixth grader that's a lot I
mean yeah well this is so no pun
intended but I feel like it's gonna get
heavy
go play so like in seventh grade I
became anorexic and so and I talked
about this a little bit I made a video
in like 2008 about it
um but I had never really talked about
it again and I didn't know if I even
want to talk about it in my draw my life
but I felt like he was like important to
like you know be honest though so I
vaguely mentioned it in my draw my life
but it was like terrible like I was
really overweight at the beginning and
then I remember and I don't know if my
sense of time is like off but it felt
like within like a month period I I felt
like I lost like 30 pounds oh wow
like I stopped eating and this was this
was like sixth grade this was seventh
grade seventh grade and do you remember
that the day that you made that choice
to I don't remember these stars how did
it how does that work
I don't remember the start but I
remember the progress because I remember
I had been going to the gym I had been
like obsessively working really hard
during gym class and even though that
sounds ridiculous like I would push
myself in gym class and I like yeah I
had joined the track team I went to the
I went to a separate gym before school
and I had gym class 6-hour so I had two
workouts a day and then track after
school and I didn't eat in between so
like there were times when I would
actually like I fainted once in choir
and my choir teacher like talk to my
parents about like what was going on and
I remember one day really specifically
like I was in science class and they
were doing roll call I guess or whatever
you'd call it attendance and my science
teacher didn't even like recognize me at
first and I realize like oh this is like
doing something like all my working out
none of my eating like it's all going
toward you know progress as a reward
that you are accomplishing what you
wanted I mean where would people call
you the fat kid or was it just something
in your mind yeah I don't remember
anybody making fun of me for being fat
but I remember hating myself for being
fat and so I lost I did lose 30 pounds I
don't know if it was in that one month
but I'm sure it was a longer span of
time but I was down to 100 pounds which
is like skin and bones but I still like
saw myself in the mirror I was like
disgustingly overweight mm-hmm and so
were the adults in your life you know
you said that your teachers talk to your
parents my teachers are talking to my
parents my parents were talking to each
other my both families so my mom and my
dad were arguing about it my dad was
claiming that like my mom wasn't feeding
me so I was going to therapy but I was
going to like into the room and I'm not
speaking to the therapist just like it
was just a show and what were you
thinking at the time we were like oh
well they think something's wrong with
me but there's nothing wrong with me I'm
just watching this situation right is
what I was thinking
and so like body image issues have been
something that I've dealt with ever
since just because like even when I was
a hundred pounds I felt like I was
disgusting like just so overweight and
gross and looking back at pictures of
myself I was like a skeleton like my
face was just empty and it like Caan
caved in you know what I mean
so starting like ninth grade in tenth
grade is kind of where I found a happy
medium with like the weight issue but it
was a couple years and it was like
really difficult a couple years everyone
in your life kind of knowing that there
was a problem you you were in denial
about it but they were still trying to
like send
therapy and this kind of thing yeah and
so what clicked I don't know well I mean
I guess the time that it all went away
was also the time that I came out really
so so we're gonna Bennett were you
wrestling coming to gross with realizing
that you were gay that was a parallel I
think it was parallel yes it was is
definitely something that I was
currently struggling with at the exact
same time so tell us tell us more about
that experience
sure parallel what was how does that
work for you um
well throughout middle school I knew I
was like in love with like my best
friend who I'm still really good friends
with um but I didn't know like if it was
just a feeling like at the time I was
dating girls and like going on dates and
like etc um but I didn't know like I
didn't know how I felt like I didn't
know any gay people I remember actually
now I'm thinking about it in middle
school my somebody like I said my mom
and my stepdad were always really
supportive and they were always like
whenever they lectured me they would say
if you ever get married
whoever you marry like you know isn't
gonna tolerate this behavior he or she
will you know but they would always use
like gender-neutral or you know and is
that something that they said to all
kids or just something they said because
they kind of they kind of saw where it
was going with you you think they only
said it to all the kids because I didn't
want me to feel like they were singling
me out okay but they would definitely
said it they were saying it for me to
hear which was really helpful but um
that still didn't like help me come to
terms with my own so they knew you were
gay before you did yeah well I I guess I
don't know if I knew or not but like I
wasn't gonna admit it you know I mean um
but yes they knew but I remember my
brother-in-law took me to work with him
one day he worked at the post office and
just so like I could like you know hang
out with him at work all day and like do
like a job shadow thing and like have
fun and just bonding or whatever and he
introduced me to one of his co-workers
who was gay and he's like if you ever
need to talk to him about anything you
can and I'm like what is he talking
about but like looking back like hey I
remember now that like okay well he was
trying to give me like somebody that I
could come out to
just be you know whatever which is super
kind and nice but like also at the time
I was like what I'm what do you mean oh
so you don't I mean in retrospect you
don't feel like it would have been
better if there to said hey listen
you're your sixth grader you don't have
life figured out you may not understand
yourself but I think at some times
League a you should think they like kind
of hinted toward things and so in eighth
or ninth grade ninth grade my mom we
were in line at the bank it was we were
banking it flag star at the time I don't
know if you're familiar flag star flag
star flag star with an L so we were in
line and my mom just turns to me and
she's like are you gay and I was like
yes and that was the end of that when
was this again ninth grade ninth grade
yeah and I never came out to my stepdad
like it was just never a thing like he I
guess after that my mom was like well
it's true like or something was that it
was that a moment of realization was
that like okay well you know what it
wasn't I think about it yes or you know
what I realized this time I realized I
had realized it in middle school okay um
and at the time I was still dating girls
and so like I had realized it and I was
still lying to my friends and I hadn't
told nobody like nobody knew and the
reason what were this what were the
reasons that you were kind of I don't
know in the closet I guess you'd say I
don't know why because it wasn't a fear
of people not accepting me I think it
was just kind of like I don't I just
reasoned with myself that it was
personal or that like nobody why should
I tell them or I don't know when was so
where you were at and I mean your how
are you know you're at 20 s from 24 24
so we're talking about the late 90s or
we time of the early - no no we're
talking about I came out so - my mom
this was what 9th grade I was 14 so 10
years ago okay yeah so we're talking
about you know 2004 so 2004 in this part
of Michigan it wasn't like oh this is
gonna be a scandalous thing no and I was
really fortunate because oakum s where I
grew up was very liberal and very like
just open-minded not necessarily liberal
but just more open-minded they were like
openly gay teachers that were openly gay
kids at the high school like it wasn't
uncommon to come out like it was yes a
big deal but like people were very
supportive and when you did you went to
the bank and I did yes no everything was
ten times better after that now every
time you go to a bank you feel like
you've really got to share something
with someone well the interesting thing
is if you think about this is that
technically that moment is probably on a
security camera tape somewhere oh my god
yeah it was in front of the ATM or was
it like inside no it was going through
the drive-through yeah you're wrong okay
so you were in the you're on camera I
mean you were in the car yes the middle
of the no is a like a line of cars
there's probably no audio but there's
like your mom looking over to you and if
you didn't you know if it was
high-resolution enough you shouldn't
talk to flex are emulate listen listen
can you go put into the archives
that's like probably not beautiful
footage yeah so ninth grade you're out
yeah and after your mom asks you that
question is that when you said okay I'm
going to start telling my friends I'm
gonna be honest actually before well I
don't I don't know when it was or who
was first if I told my mom first I told
some of my friends first but I remember
the reason I came out in high school to
all my friends was because I was kind of
outed I had told one of my friends who I
don't even speak to I don't even like
know if I'm Facebook friends with her
still I had told her that I was like I
had a super big crush on one of my best
friends and she thought he was gay too
and so she was thinking oh okay well I'm
gonna match make this up and I'm gonna
make this happen these two closeted gays
and lo and behold he's straight and so
she goes to his girlfriend and says
Tyler has a crush on Eric and she the
girlfriend freaks out thinks at me and
Eric are like together something's going
on there she's starting to spread rumors
about me and Eric like something's
happening and Eric doesn't even know
that I like him so this is all like
highschool drama but I remember so I was
in the musical Grease at the time at the
high school and we were about to go on
for a performance for the high school we
had previews before the opening weekend
and I found out that
had told and I found out that everyone
knew but I didn't know that everybody
knew and so if this is like ten minutes
before going on stage and so we all go
on stage the lights are off I can feel
myself crying I have the opening line of
the show and what role I was eugene the
like nerd and like I said the opening
line so I'm crying on stage before the
like the curtain goes up and I'm like
just freaking out and I like wipe it all
away I'm like I need to like perform and
it was like in the curtain goes up and I
deliver and then as soon as my thing was
done I left stage went to the greenroom
went to the boys locker room and just
cried and cried and cried and cried and
cried and then as soon as was done I
avoided everyone I like ran home and I
was like what am I gonna do like
everyone knows I need to talk to Eric so
I call Eric and I tell him like I'm gay
I know you've heard like I don't I don't
want this to affect our friendship like
I'm like leaving silence for him to be
like I'm gay too that's clearly that
didn't happen and he's like don't worry
everything's fine Beauvoir so like
anybody can say that while you they're
pressured on the phone but I was just
more concerned about okay how is it
gonna be the next day when I go into
school mm-hmm and so were the tears
mostly related to how this was gonna
affect your relationship with him with
all my friends hey just the origin yet
the fact that it just kind of everything
came out the way yeah in a way that you
didn't it was wrong not at all how I
plan right and I didn't know how it was
how I had planned but like this was just
out of my control and like somebody who
appreciates control it was just so the
next day I go into school and it's a
long long hallway from the entrance
where all the busses drop off kids and
like the classrooms and lockers so I'm
walking down the hallway and I'm just
dreading the first moment where I see
Eric because I'm like he's gonna just
he's gonna hate me he's gonna like not
want to be friends he's gonna act like
he's not even he doesn't even know me
because that was just how I thought
people reacted to gays mm-hmm and I
remember I was at the far end of the
hall he
the other far end of the hall and we
were like kind of walking toward each
other we see each other and my heart is
like racing because I'm like this is
gonna determine how coming out goes like
his response is gonna like I guess
either make me not come out to anybody
or I guess that was like very dramatic
but like that's how I was thinking and
when we were like approaching each other
he's just like hugged me like a very
long extended hug and he like whispered
to me he's like don't worry nothing is
different we're still best friends
everything is fine let's go to class and
then it was like completely normal
everything was fine I'm like I thought
it was like the biggest most important
thing and like it was it was important
but like so not important at the same
time like it just didn't matter okay so
a lot
sorry that's a lot a lot went down right
at the beginning of high school which
just the transition to high school is a
big deal for a lot of people so you're
coming to these very formative
conclusions at the beginning of high
school and then I assume your friendship
with Eric continues through high school
don't stay at the same high school for
four years and so you get involved in
drama club like what was the rest of
high school like as you begin to figure
out who you are high school was great
high school was like the best and I
think honestly it was because I had the
support group of my family my friends in
drama club my choir I became drama club
president I was very involved in like
productions talent show stuff I was very
close with like the choir teacher I was
yearbook editor in chief like very
involved in like everything in high
school
and I just loved
I just loved high school it was like the
best because it was just social hour all
the time for me and especially now that
I was like out and open and just like
unapologetically me it was like I could
just like have fun and like I I'd never
felt like that in middle school mm-hm so
did you become popular I I guess so yeah
but like in a way that like a choir kid
in a Drama like
club kid will be popular like popular
for the drama club now when you say
choir we are you talking like glee club
are you talking about no it was like yes
yeah it was chorus they call it um oh
they do so I was in that and we go yeah
yeah middle school chorus we I was at
took course yeah I was in the band loser
that's that's the difference right there
but choir was good and like I I took on
I guess leadership roles within choir
and drama and you started figuring out
more about long-term what you want to do
at that point yeah and I think my
relationships with my choir teacher and
my drama teacher in my yearbook teacher
inspired me to want to be a teacher
because that's what I always thought I
was gonna be okay so I went through high
school thinking okay well this is the
route I'm gonna go I'm gonna go to
Michigan State they have Michigan State
they have a great education program I'm
gonna teach like middle school or high
school or something like that also I
guess my relationship with my choir
teacher from middle school the one who
would talk to my parents about my eating
disorder that really inspired me who I'm
still in contact with today Facebook
friends and so like the teachers in my
life really defined what I wanted to do
I guess yeah and who you wanted to be
yeah so when did that path deviate and
ultimate end up ultimately end up in
YouTube land sure from did you go to
Michigan State yes so I went to Michigan
State I which is a five minute drive
from where my parents lived okay so not
far at all and I went to school thinking
okay I'm going to go into education I
didn't have many scholarships and being
like one of a million kids I in my
family I'm paying for everything myself
so I have loans up my ass and I know
that I have to work through college and
I had worked all throughout high school
that since I was fourteen I've had jobs
from like Arby's to McDonald's to coffee
shop back to McDonald's and then like
now in college
I was working all throughout college so
I was a telemarketer which I was so good
at I was selling I had to call alumni
and ask them to donate to their
graduating or the program that they
graduated from so did you guilt trip
these the alumni oh my gosh yes
well you can see who you're calling and
I wasn't supposed to do this but I did
it
why would their picture no no you could
see like statistics so like their name
what year they graduated what program
they were in how much they usually
donate stuff like that so you can try to
like get them to up you know how much
they're donating this year stuff like
that but I'm very persuasive and so
you're not supposed to hang up on people
before the answer but I would if they
were young and I would just look for the
old ladies cause like that's who I could
speak to and I could just get this is
probably bad to admit but I could get so
much money out of them because like I
was just like a sweet little old boy
just talking to the talking to them
about their grandkids and what it was
like back in the day and and then I'm
like oh well you know I don't want to
keep you too long but like I was just
wondering if you donate to like the
school that's helped you out so much and
that's currently helping me out so much
and just like I loved it it was like a
little game to me right no so looks we
took credit card no I don't have a
credit card you're gonna direct my
reverse mortgage right back into this
account everyone so in at one point I
was like the number one caller in the
room out of like 200 people so I was
very good at it and it was where I met
my first boyfriend he set across for me
he was straight at the time yeah oh you
you broke him well I showed him the
light what's the proper terminology life
he gave him mm-hmm I gave him right up
yeah and I just I just met up with him
in San Francisco him and his new
boyfriends like two weeks ago but yeah
we met in telemarketing and then dated
that's its own doesn't sound romantic
but it was we were each other's first
boyfriends it was like a big deal it was
like you know
uh he's like one of the loves of my life
so yeah did you only conduct your
relationship with headset song know what
things got no but that would be like
kinky or something I'm imagining it
would just be professional yeah I'm sure
Harry very preferred
oh they speak I would I would flirt with
him all the time though and at the
telemarketing place and then one weekend
he was like it was st. Patrick's Day and
he's like what are you doing for st.
Patrick's Day let's like go out to the
like the frat house and I'm like okay
thinking like this hot straight guy
wants to hang out and then like half a
sip of a wine cooler later he's like all
over it so very straight indeed and then
we dated for a year
well maybe was just the wine cooler was
it Bartles and Jaymes it was banana
vodka every time every time some mixed
drink okay on a tangent
okay but at some point I mean so what
you're in college what years are you in
college so I was pretty recently yeah I
mean YouTube's already started in 2007
so okay so yeah I can get into that so
in 2007 I thought again I thought I was
going into education and I realized very
quickly that I hated teaching I had T
aid a little bit in high school I was
like an assistant teacher but that was
like fun because it worked like my
friends but then in college I remember
one class I had to tutor one guy he was
like 30 years old his name was Ibrahim
Abraham I don't know if you're out there
you Brown everybody done did right I had
to teach him English and which was just
I had no patience whatsoever and so I
thought okay well if I don't have the
patience for one person I'm not gonna
have patience for thirty of these people
so I changed my major I dropped that
class changed my major to communication
because I knew communication was just
very you owe it all to Ibrahim Ibrahim
Ibrahim Ibrahim changed everything and I
went into communication with the focus
in public relations marketing social
media that kind of stuff and at the same
time in 2007 it was September 18th 2007
probably a week prior I had started to
watch YouTube September eighteenth was
when I made my account and I watched
there was this one guy I'm sure you guys
know i'm william sledd yeah oh yeah he
was the reason why I started watching
you gay dude vlogger yes so he was
the southern vlogger just very fashion
oriented he didn't really edit much she
just talked into a camera he was like a
full-blown personality mm-hmm and at the
same time I well I saw that he was just
talking into his macbook and I had just
bought my macbook and I was like you
know what I could do that and so um
September 18th 2007 I mean my account
and I was always so like afraid like
should I use my full name cuz I had
always known like you're not supposed to
use your name on the internet oh wow
but william sledd did so I was like okay
I'm gonna use Tyler Oakley and I'm so
glad I did because I'm like you see like
people with the most random usernames
I'm like that must suck
you're like eleven numbers right you
want to avoid the numbers again so I put
up my first video and at the time I saw
he was talking to his friends like just
talking like about like stories with his
friends stuff like that going to the
mall mm-hmm making fun of people's
clothes so I was talking to my friends
Eric who you all know Dolan who is my
best friend from sixth grade and Rachel
who is my co-editor-in-chief from
yearbook class so my three best friends
we had all gone off to different
colleges so my first video is literally
just 10 minutes long me talking to the
three of them directly showing them
around my dorm room
and just telling stories about
orientation and just like okay so at
what point did it switch to being an
audience at large uh well it was a slow
growth so I remember I remember very
distinctly when I one of my videos had a
hundred of 100 views because I was like
I was posting it on Facebook but I
didn't like have a hundred friends like
or people that cared so I remember
thinking okay well there must be people
that like you know william sledd has
some type of viral you know appeal he
had 80,000 views on a video like that
was insane I got a hundred views on a
video that's in
saying so I knew people were watching
for some capacity for whatever reason
and I remember just making more videos
making more general videos talking about
like pop culture less about like
specific things about my life but more
like broad stuff that anybody could
relate to not just Rachael Dolan Eric
and I remember one video it was about
like hate speech that's what it was
about
I had asked a whole bunch of LGBT
vloggers that I had watched and loved to
also make videos so it was like a big
collaboration project that I had like
orchestrated and YouTube back in the day
when it was like something worthwhile
they put it on the front page right and
in that day I remember I like I was like
freaking out it's crying called my mom I
was like this is like this is everything
but wha
I gained like 3,000 subscribers that day
like which was huge Ben Ben and so at
that point you were kind of off to the
races of I'm going to target an audience
well yeah because I never do obsessive
emotive I didn't have a motive of I want
to be a youtuber yes sir what I mean
though because I was gonna ask that
question that first video because it was
never in my like plan to be a william
sledd like I never thought I could
aspired but inspire like and you were
like that looks fun but not I want to be
the next william sledd I know well at
the time like I had just started to
figure out like Oh some people are
getting paid for this like that's crazy
like that'll never happen that's like
the top ten people like that's it
so like I never had an aspiration of I
want this to be my full-time job I never
even knew it could be a full-time job
because it wasn't a full-time job for
anybody then but I'm trying to think
when it wouldn't kind of hit that like
it could be more than a hobby and that
was probably after college because
throughout college I still thought I'm
gonna do social media for companies okay
for I'm gonna do you know public
relations I that was my focus public
relations and that was like I had
internships for public relations
thinking like this is what I'm gonna do
at the time all the YouTube stuff was
just like a fun hobby and it was giving
me jobs throughout college so I moved
from telemarketing to
making videos for the career services
Network so I would make videos about how
to make a resume or how to go to an
interview or how to write a thank-you
email you know stuff like that
so when did it switch to I am a youtuber
I'm gonna give this a go or I'm
responding to a particular opportunity
or I remember getting fan mail I think
was when it kind of like like freaks Mia
not freaked me out but like opened my
eyes that this is like affecting people
and this is something that could be
something
it wasn't fan mail like you know peal
box stuff it was in my youtube inbox
which nobody uses anymore but in my
youtube inbox somebody told me that they
didn't commit suicide because they were
watching my videos and I was like holy
this is something like this is it's not
just you know somebody talking about
fashion or somebody doing a makeup
tutorial or somebody just talking about
whatever I was talking about it was
something that was may have helped me or
may have made things smoother for me if
I had it when I was back in middle
school you know I mean and and what kind
of mental shift did that create for you
um or change your goals or I don't think
it changed my goals it just made me more
conscious of my impact and more careful
of my message because it was like okay
well mmm the things I'm saying could
affect somebody's life you certainly
realize like a new sense of
responsibility yeah yeah which is like
scary and terrifying and like especially
when it's just a fun hobby it's like
okay well now there's like some social
repercussions like that could be you
know I mean yeah even to that point even
to when I graduated college it was still
just a hobby and so you must have taken
a some sort of normal job right after it
go yeah so I graduated college my
freshman year of college I met Cory who
was my RA and he was one of my best
friends we did a collab channel together
he started doing YouTube too he
graduated a few years before me so when
I graduated college I knew I didn't want
to say in Michigan because there's no
public relations job said I wanted to
take I was thinking I wanted to do like
celebrity PR or something like that I
knew
to move to the west coast and in the
meantime Cory had just sat around he was
working at a bank and flag star that
flag star
I no no no he was manning the security
security tapes
yes flag strum so I told them I was like
okay well I'm moving to the west coast
you should come with me let's just pick
up and go so I graduated high school him
and I were thinking about difficulties
yes college I graduated college him and
I were thinking about different places
to go one of them was San Francisco so
we flew up to San Francisco just to like
check it out for the weekend we fell in
love with the city within a day we set
up a meeting not a meeting I'm just an
open house to see an apartment just to
see what apartments were like for the
next day we went to that open house or
you know whatever it's called where you
check out the apartment and sign the
lease before leaving oh wow you were
like all right we're in you're doing
this which is kind of like I guess kind
of like me like I'm just very like if I
just feel good about it I'll do it
whereas Corey's a lot more alike okay
well I have to check this I've checked
that I was just like let's just do it
let's just forced his hand I did so did
that turn out to be a good decision oh
my god it was the most important
decision of my life
moving away from Michigan was huge
because I would have gotten stuck in
what everybody gets stuck in I feel it's
just what they think is an easy path to
take I was so glad that like I picked up
and move and it was yes it was so
expensive to make the move and to ship
everything out and to you know do
whatever but it was like a whole new
life and like I didn't have a job
so like I've moved out there like just
hoping I would find a job at some point
which I did I found a job doing I was a
communication intern for a fashion
website which is not my passion but it
was just like something hmm and then it
turned into a full-time job there I got
hired on full time and it was just a
startup so it was a very it was like
five people in a room and I thought like
oh my god I'm doing it I'm living the
dream I have a career going on I commute
to work on the but around the train like
this is so adult of me and at the same
time still doing YouTube stuff just as
fun um and beginning to see any income
through YouTube at that point a little
bit but like not like anything it was
like play money in by play money I mean
like maybe the tiniest bit like nothing
like right I never had like a brand deal
I never did anything like a couple
hundred bucks here and Hubble hundred
bucks here and there yes which still
felt like awesome to me because it was
not my intention to make money from it
and I so I I had that job for about a
year I got a new job with a LGBT non non
profit doing social media stuff I'm
helping them out with that doing like
social media correspondent work and also
producing stuff so we produced a lot of
like video content and I kind of saw
like oh my god there's like more
production value that I could do because
I had always just talked into a camera I
could I felt like oh my gosh there's a
whole world out here and I was traveling
to LA for that a lot and I was like okay
well la is where a lot of youtubers are
so we would use like youtubers and like
the content and stuff like that and that
was when I started having more of a
relationship with the YouTube community
in LA and kind of seeing that work out
and then that job kind of ran its course
and the business was not doing so well
and like it was just me and my boss and
so like it was like a lot of stress
between two people and as far as like
paying me it was getting more and more
difficult to do because I could tell
like it was not going well and so I was
like I was talking to Cory about it one
day and I was like you know what what if
I just like tried youtube because at the
time a lot of youtubers were doing it
and I had just gone to VidCon which was
probably like my second VidCon or my
third VidCon or something by then and
this is or could have been sneaked it
was ii ii ii ii ii met before you moved
or right after you moved okay
I think 1012 is when when everything
changed mmm it was summer 2012 I had
just gone to VidCon I had a meeting with
my management company that I now work
with my network big frame and I at the
time I had not taken any meetings
because I had seen like other youtubers
taking meetings going off and like
signing
and just signing away their YouTube
lives I'm like okay well I've been doing
this for how long I don't need anybody
taking a cut of my hundred dollars every
couple months I don't need anybody's
help like setting things up because at
the time like I had done a couple
speaking gigs and I had negotiated that
myself so they were telling me like oh
we can negotiate deals for you but I'm
like I do all this myself
I don't even buddies help and I was glad
I took the meeting because I had just
reluctantly said no to everything but I
took the meeting and we talked about
career possibilities and about possibly
doing YouTube full-time and possibly
doing this or that or like directions
that I wanted to go and I had never
really considered like oh not only can I
do YouTube full-time but I can use
YouTube in my hobby of YouTube to attain
even bigger things like I never thought
like I could do speaking things or I
never thought that I could work with
brands or I never thought that I could
do red carpet things or anything like
that like that just never process in my
mind that was something I could do like
celebrity stuff like being on a red
carpet or you know what I mean like that
just seemed so far away in distant from
the hobby that was YouTube for me so
talking to them and seeing that like oh
I could do hosting things or I could do
red carpet things or anything like that
it opened my eyes that like okay well if
I want to take a chance I can and so at
the time when I was hating my job and it
was not really doing well I decided I'm
gonna just try to do full-time YouTube
and so what changed I mean how did you
do that like what was the transition
well at the time a lot of things were
picking up on my channel in January of
that year I had decided to commit myself
to a video every week whereas before I
would do it maybe every couple months so
there was no consistency so when I made
the announcement and when I told my
people like it's coming every week at
the time I was getting probably 30,000
views of video in that January and then
I was making a video every single week
and it was very consistent and I was
being really creative and I was just
really dedicating myself to editing and
just being better at editing and filming
and everything like that my views picked
up and picked up and picked up and
picked up and I remember it went huge
right before VidCon when I made a video
about one direction and it was the first
time I ever mentioned them it was me
just going through between magazines
looking
one direction in talking about one
direction and it went I guess I always
think it went viral but like
numbers-wise it didn't really like it it
got like 300,000 views which was just
out of control for me and I had never
seen anything like that and from there
my subscriber amount grew a lot my views
were starting to like pick up and
waterfall and like just spill over to
like all my old videos and like new
videos were getting more and more views
and then in October you were a super
node captain yeah yeah holy crap that
was forever ago that's how we met yeah
that's through that yeah oh my god what
about the people who I would assume
would label your characterize you as
okay the gay vlogger whether they would
say it that way or think of it that way
versus the vlogger who happens to be gay
I mean how do you feel about that how
does that you know what weird meow
people always say like I'm putting on a
lisp
I don't even thought I had a lisp but
then I complained about this and my all
my friends were like you have a lisp
I'd like didn't even I don't think I do
still will analyze the tape you know
I've been thinking about that I think I
have an extended s is what I've been
told is what I mean if anything it is
yeah the slightest like we're talking
about a 10% okay well if that 10% so
weird because once people know that I'm
gay on YouTube they like seem to like
critique everything that I do was like
around the gay community like oh he's a
bad example for the gay community he
thinks he's like the spokesperson for
the gays or bah blah blah or he's
putting on a lisp but he's trying to be
over effeminate or try to be a
stereotype bla bla I'm just being me
like it's just very like it's weird for
me to see that critique and the weirdest
part is it usually comes from the gay
community right well it seems to me that
there's a there's a little bit of you
know it kind of cuts both ways because
you know being gay is is exceptional in
one sense and the fact that you're in
the minority right and so you're in the
minority on YouTube which is gonna bring
a certain kind of audience
the same time a certain set of
responsibilities yeah and probably give
you give you a certain kind of
opportunity but then give you these
expectations that your fans place on you
so how do you how do you live in that
exceptionality it's like it's
frustrating sometimes like I said like
cuz all I'm trying to do is just be my
best self like I I am I understand that
there's a sense of responsibility to be
a good representation but I'm not I've
never claimed to be the voice of the
gays on YouTube I've never claimed to be
you know anything like that and I see
that thrown around all the time like he
thinks he's the voice of all the gays
like I'm just like what are you like
where is this coming from so I always
think okay well if people are gonna have
this expectation of me I can only be my
best self and I can only put my best
foot forward and I can only be the you
know the gay that I am I can't represent
everybody and I never claimed to be
never claimed to or never want to so in
the same light okay well if I have this
influence then I should use it to help
give exposure to other facets of the
LGBTQ community so when it comes to you
know sharing up-and-coming youtubers
that are different representations of
the community that's how I reconciled
that you know that kind of
responsibility what's what's next for
Tyler Oakley what's next
YouTube is always next
I like I've always said like I want to
do it until I hate it and like I in
haven't even like it hasn't even
slightly bugged me you know what I mean
so I imagine YouTube will be part of the
story for a long long long long time
well listen man I I really appreciate
this felt like we've gotten to know you
a lot better and I'm sorry I talked to
your ear off no this is this is great
this is by design you guys you made
quite a beautiful biscuits your biscuit
thank you that's what you just made
that's the kindest thing anybody
[Music]
and there it was a conversation with
Tyler Oakley yeah we'll be contacting
flag star bank if there are any
representatives out there I don't know a
flag star still around but we're gonna
see what those security tapes are still
available and we'll be analyzing this
podcast to see what kind of Lisp Tyler
has just for his you know just for
personal feedback Justin just to tell
him how he's coming across and we are
thankful to Tyler for being so honest
and having such a sincere conversation
with us after we were done recording he
said to us that there were some things
that he hadn't shared before and you
know that that's what you get with it
either biscuit people you know this
isn't just the same old biscuit you know
this isn't you know you you've haven't
had this biscuit before you know this
isn't the kind of this isn't a frozen
thing this isn't a put in the microwave
kind of thing this is your grandma
invited you over set you down put in
some fresh ingredients she does it a
little bit different every time
that's the bottom line here is where
your grandmother we are your grandmother
that these two middle-aged men are your
grandmother now and that you just need
to accept that some grandmother's have
facial hair my grandmother did once you
reach a certain age they don't matter my
grandmother had a pretty strong beard I
mean it was like peach fuzz but you know
like when you got close to her and you
kissed on her cheek or something you're
like yep she's got peach fuzz all over
the bottom of her face really and I
liked it cuz it was soft did she charge
admission when you came over she was not
she was not the bearded lady wasn't I
got a thing you had to get close you had
to be your grandson you had to be in a
kissing scenario thank you for being a
loyal listener and ear biscuit partaker
I like to set your biscuit ear but
nobody's really into that yet yeah it's
no one is into it I mean I can just feel
the vibe thank you for your feedback
your comments on Soundcloud and on
Twitter and other places where you can
communicate
with us thanks for sharing this link the
iTunes and SoundCloud
[Music]
[Music]